Hello everyone.
This is Youngsang Cho\h
And welcome to JADAM
As you know from the other videos,\h
I have been farming 60 different kinds of crops\h
every year for researching the effects of JADAM\h
natural pesticides.
And with those results, I was able to publish\h\h
2 books on organic pest and disease management.
And in today's episode, I want to talk about\h\h
controlling aphids.
Which is a very\h\h
common topic between farmers to gardeners.
I have already released all the recipes in\h\h
the book called JADAM Organic pest and diseases
control. But In this video, I want to show a\h\h
little more straightforward result of using JADAM
natural pesticide and how it affects the aphid.\h\h
and I will also show you the comparison of
commercial eco-friendly products VS the\h\h
JADAM one at the end of the video.
If you have been watching my channel,\h
You have probably noticed what I repeatedly\h
say about pest and disease control.\h
"Once you have managed to control aphid\h
and powdery mildew, you are good to go"\h
It means once you treat those two things\h
you can be a master of natural pesticides.\h
All we use is the simple solution,\h
and here we are again I'm showing\h\h
you the same ingredient
from the previous videos.\h
And if you are watching for the first time, I\h
know you won't believe it but yes it does work.\h
With the combination of these 5 ingredients, you\h
can control almost all pests and diseases that\h
can occur during the farming season.
Yes, all means from thrips to anthracnose.\h
One big different thing about JADAM pest solution\h
is that you have to make the JWA, JHS, and JS.\h
This could be the cons of this technology,
however,\h
in this way, you will spend about\h
20-time lesser amount of dollars\h
and I guarantee that every JADAM solutions\h
are powerful and most eco-friendlier than\h
commercial chemical or organic pest\h
and disease solutions in the market.
\h
which I think is attractive\h
to manufacture by yourself.\h
I will put up the link on the top so if you are\h
new, please watch other videos on how to make\h
JWA and JS.
It is a truly great solution,\h\h
but You will need to pretest all your\h
solution before spraying them in the\h
a large field, you will not want to have\h
bad side effects from a large dosage.\h
Anything excessive is always not a good solution\h
and we all learned it from our childhood.\h
For that, I wrote down all precautions\h
that could happen with the ingredient.\h
So please read it before trying it by yourself.
Now let's begin with the life cycle of aphids.\h
We know that aphid is one of the most\h
destructive pests to plants in temperate regions.\h
They are active from April to October, and they\h
become an adult within a week and live up to\h
one month. You might think it is short\h
and why do we need to think about them.\h
But the real problem comes from their babies.\h
It does not have a mating period and reproduces an\h
average of 15 baby aphids per day and which is not\h
the egg.
The egg\h\h
needs a few days to hatch but babies,\h
start eating right after birth.\h
Moreover, all those offspring\h
babies are mostly female,\h
which means if you fail to control\h
all in a certain period your\h\h
crop will be filled with aphids.
This is the reason why they\h\h
could earn the title of destructive\h
agricultural pest in the entire globe.\h
If you are a farmer or gardener,\h
you know what I'm talking about.\h
Even if there are other solutions to treat\h
aphids, it does not eliminate all but a few.\h
Killing a few aphids does\h
not help the farmers at all.\h
Because survived one will\h
reproduce their babies again.\h
We need something stronger but safer\h
and more reliable way to treat them.\h
And you will no longer worry\h
because you are watching my videos.\h
Once you successfully control aphids, you can\h
make other solutions for different problems.\h
This is the picture that I have\h
taken while researching aphids.\h
The leaves were clean before,
but we needed them to\h\h
be tested with our solutions.
so, I have not sprayed anything for a while.\h
And we don't worry about the plant.
Because we know it will die anyway\h\h
with the solutions.
As I have explained repeatedly in all my videos,\h
that it is mandatory to use soft\h
water to make JWA, JS, and JHS\h
When we are talking about soft water, which\h
means it contains low calcium ions and\h
magnesium ions.
So where can we collect soft water?\h
well, it is quite easy to find one from the\h
rain, distilled water, air conditioner water,\h
dehumidifier water, and also from the ground.\h
Or you can make your own water softener.\h
But please do test the water by yourself with JWA.\h
And there is the reason why we tell\h
you the importance of soft water,\h
It is because of the wetting\h
properties of the JADAM solution.\h
As you can see from the picture, a solution used\h
with soft water will wet the leaves completely\h
This means the effect and success rate\h
of pest solutions will also increase.\h
Let me briefly show you how\h
to test the water with JWA.\h
Simply add a few drops of JWA, when the water is\h
clear for a couple of minutes then it means the\h
water is used for pest solution.
But if not, it means the water has less wetting\h\h
properties and it will leave a mark on the
the surface of the leaves, then\h\h
eventually those marks will build\h
up and block the photosynthesis of\h
the crop.
Moving on to the JHS,\h
If you have used the correct water, then\h
the color of the solution remains the same.\h
But if not, it will quickly turn brighter.\h
It could also happen if you stored it the wrong\h
way, if the JHS is fermented, it will be useless.\h
You have to store it airtight, and you have\h
to boil the herbs right after collecting them.\h
I have also posted a video on how to make JHS with\h
simple tools. So, if you haven't watched it yet,\h
Please go ahead and watch\h
the other videos as well.\h
If you have purchased one of our\h
books, I have also elaborated\h\h
in detail on how it can be made and
the recipe for each and every solution.\h
But if you are a gardener with no access to\h
ginkgo JHS and don't have enough time to make all\h
of this,
You can just use the JWA alone, by increasing the\h\h
amount of JWA, the pest control rate increase.
And another solution\h\h
is to add sodium hydroxide along with JWA.
As you can see from this picture,\h\h
I have elaborated all the ratios.\h
During the prevention period, you\h
can add 5 liters in 500 liters, then gradually\h
increase the ratio as shown in the picture.\h
So, I have just told you that\h
Ginko JHS won't be that necessary,\h
But there is a pest that only ginko JHS can treat.
Which are stink bugs, flea beetle, leaf miner,\h\h
mosquito, and more.
So please use JHS if you are facing these pests.\h
Gingko is one of our favorites, but you can\h
also find alternative herbs to make it with.\h
And there are some pests that make the leaves\h
curl inward, such as leaf-curling aphids.\h
In this case, you will have to focus on\h
winter control and prevention control.\h
Because the solution won't be effective if it\h
does not contact the aphid's living habitat.\h
And utilize the kickback reaction of pest solution\h
on the landscape fabric when you are spraying\h
on crops in which the leaves\h
are all located on the ground.\h
If you look at the footage here, these are the\h
aphid that I collected from the apple tree.\h
The apple tree leaf has lots of\h
hair on the back of the leaf.\h
Which makes it harder for\h
farmers to control aphids.\h
Abondance hair indicates less penetration rate.
Therefore, I have added 20 liters\h\h
of JWA on a 500-liter ratio.
Now I have sprayed the solution,\h\h
and as you can see that the aphids are not moving.
Which is a good sign.\h
The shot was taken during hot weather and I\h
do not recommend spraying the solution under\h
the sun due to the evaporation rate.\h
However, we can still\h
observe that it is effective.\h
For a better close-up view,\h
I brought the leaves inside.\h
It has been about 1 and a half hours.\h
And from then I filmed for 7\h
hours straight with timelapse.\h
And it looks like the control rate is about 98%
I have added 20 litters of JWA into 500Liters of\h\h
water which is equivalent to 800ml in 20
litters of spray bags.\h
However, it is not so necessary to add such an\h
amount. You can definitely go lower than this one.\h
Now let's move on to the final\h
comparison with the commercial products.\h
Of course, these products that I am using\h
is also qualified organic pest solutions\h\h
specially made
for aphid.\h
The middle one is the JADAM solution and the\h
left and right are the commercial product.\h
As you could see here, both sides\h
of the leaves is not wet enough.\h
Which means there is no sign of penetration.
But the JADAM solution in the middle is fully wet.\h
I filmed this footage for seven hours and from\h
my point of view, these products cannot be\h
called aphid solutions. Because\h
at first, it didn't work right\h\h
so I sprayed double the amount but
still could see nothing much changed.\h
As time passes the leaves are getting dry, and the\h
left and right leaves, you could barely see the\h
aphids because it all moved away.
I will show you how it looked at the first stage.\h
You could see there are big differences\h
between the before and after shots.\h
The commercially available pest solutions are\h
expensive and the result is very disappointing.\h
I thought it would have at least a 95% of control\h
rate, but most of the aphids just ran away.\h
I don't think all organic pest\h
solutions have this kind of problem.\h
But I am disappointed with the price and the\h
effects of these famously known organic pest\h
solutions.\h
Researching pest and disease control is not a\h
privilege of scientists and professors from the\h
laboratory or university research team.
Anyone can start researching things they want to.\h
Just grab a sprayer and start\h
to make your own recipe.
\h
So lastly, I would also like to speak\h
about the tools for spraying pesticides.\h
Just spraying the pest solution is not everything,
The tool also plays a big role in agriculture.\h
In the next video, I will show you how to make\h
a sprayer stick that is easy to make and very\h
effective with the JADAM solution.
I hope you have enjoyed the video.\h
If you are interested in our\h
book, please go to the link below.\h
And I will back with more interesting videos.
Thank you for watching.